si absolument génial avec un m 4 x 6
pour les vacances c'est que ça se voit
tout de suite à la rentrée
alors tu adores ça s'est bien passé des
vacances
excuse-moi théodore est ce que tu
pourrais être un peu plus explicite
[Musique]
tu es qui toi que notre monde c'est
squeeze et aujourd'hui vous l'aurez
deviné grâce à cette superbe ou pas
introduction que on est sur la démo de
ssx
enfin le jeu va bientôt sortir dans un
ou deux jours donc on va faire la méga
course of the death de la mort qui tue
across map m
jeffrey j que de la merde mais on va
prendre nous et donc la personne qui
nous gardent un petit peu tout je pense
alors c'est parti je vais pas vous
expliquer la démo ou quoi bon je ne sais
pas une vidéo test ou une vidéo je vous
présente le géo bois puisque de façon
vous avez en grande partie jouée et oui
j'ai un goût bizarre parce que c'est le
matin donc j'ai une voix plutôt bizarre
sachant que en plus je suis incroyable
ans malade et ça ça fait quand même déjà
une semaine pourrait peut-être que
j'aille je vais bouger mon que chez le
médecin
team fait ses classes chez le médecin
qui sont en train de jouer jean et jean
loup lapointe il fait chaud au coeur et
moi je vous réponds pas que l enfant
j'ai pas donc tout à l'heure je vais
aller acheter le jeu enfin je vais
essayer d'aller acheter le veut en fait
apparemment il faut gratter un petit peu
auprès des vendeurs puisqu'il
normalement ils reçoivent aujourd'hui
mais ils peuvent le rendre qu'à partir
du 1er mars ou alors je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils achètent un truc pour avoir
l'exclusivité de vendre avons quoi parce
que du coup ils volent des clients aux
autres et je me suis dit du coup je vais
essayer de gratter mais est ce que tout
cela va être fonctionnel est ce que je
vais arriver le faire ouais monsieur
veut assassiner way
et est ce que le monsieur va dire bon à
lezoux bon voilà ce qu'il va faire à
l'échelon sympa est-ce qu'à faire non
c'est mort 1er mars aussi à faire oh
[ __ ] c'est ce quiz septembre qui passe
au dessus
j'aimerais tellement et là je prendrai
jouer je suivrai merci à toi jeune
padawan et je m'en irai avec mes quatre
cuillères devait d'ailleurs se dresse
pas bref on va arrêter de dire que des
conneries au néant le tweak est bleu
faut qu'on passe en or oui nous sommes
en or nous sommes dans l'art est partout
les chemins nous prenons la branche
oui c'est bon enfin un moindre mal under
la chanson de souletins tout le temps la
même chanson et ils vous savez
d'ailleurs en parlant de bons de
chansons qui a un rapport avec le son
qui a rapport avec le casque qui a
rapport et je me prends de trondheim
dans la gueule non non c'est pas de
rapport avec ces derniers on est on est
pas mal disait ah vous savez que là par
exemple j'ai je me suis j'ai fait
l'acquisition mais comme dirait des gens
courent pro j'ai fait l'acquisition d'un
traitant à exprom cela mais vous savez
je ne commande pas avec tout simplement
parce que j'arrive pas vous avez trouvé
ça vraiment qu'on est très très très con
mais ça un truc je n'arrive pas à
commenter avec mon tritton ax pro genre
ça me stresse je sais que ça peut vous
paraître con mais je sais pas j'ai
mentionné dans ma bulle dans ma plus
longue ouest eu steve jobs dit chance et
je sais pas je ça me stresse calment
j'arrive pas à commenter je perds les
eaux je vais que de la merde et on a
fait un score complètement pourri quel
score de merde on en fait ya des
techniques il faut être un petit peu
concentré ce que je ne suis absolument
pas alors qu'il est en enjeu faire de
mariée mère de merde et ce que j'espère
dans ce fait ces six c'est que ce sera
pas tout le temps les trois [ __ ] de
même chanson en boucle quoi est ce qu on
a bouffé les trois chansons alors il ya
là celle de rap un peu à la fin puisque
j'ai présentement celle de rap un peu à
la fin il ya celle
un peu techno est une daube step enfin
genre doudoune du voile a compris mais
pourquoi je recommence encore et c'est
quoi ce bordel
attendez on va faire le l'autre mode de
jeu donc qui est le mode tout était fort
en gros faut faire le plus de clics et
j'avoue que les trous qui on a en
bouffant on en entend un tas de trucs
c'est assez impressionnant c'est quoi le
prochain treki non non non non il faut
prendre lui regardez il ya déjà marqué
les bonus au dessus pour avoir lui dans
la démo vous en voyez juste une demande
de parrainage donc depuis le menu de la
démo vous pouvez envoyer me demander
parrainage et lui l'atrix +15 dont il
faut prendre lui en tout cas j'espère
vraiment que le vendeur va le lâcher en
vous imaginez le lâche mais laisse
tomber je je rentre en courant baisser
son pantalon coiffe un sergent ça sera
incroyable un puce passe devant la gare
donc je me taperais bien là on a un ça
va
j'adorerais franchement je l'adoré
d'ailleurs je vais tête chalet avec deux
fans de marie fin de fans aux abonnés de
ma rue qui me suivait tout est gelé
pourquoi pas venir avec moi alors je
pense qu'il peut mais qu'est ce que je
vais aider la femme jo watts en parle au
nom mais non mais non ok bon bah c'est
parti le score de mer noire alors là
vous êtes prévenus vous êtes prévenus
dutil d'un d'un air désespéré puisque je
le suis heureux mais bon tu mets genre
projet trick voyez gelé tout le temps
c'est impressionnant c'est un truc ça ne
me lâche pas le plein tous les chemins
ça me revient c'est gavant ça recommence
à manger piqué au fait des nouvelles de
jay z il est un des visages manger c'est
un déménagement pour ceux qui suivent
jay z
il n'aura pas internet à partir du 6
mars jusqu'au je sais pas quand donc
vous le dire
histoire que vous croyez pas que c'est
devenu un gros effectif de merde qu'une
dépression suicidaire non c'est juste
qu'ils déménagent pour cent des ménages
dans la même ville
nash pas alors la france est une équipe
à molsheim équipe a mené les siens
restent avec moi
alors c'est parti je viens d'avoir la
bombe c'est une partie totalement lâché
que vous avez sous les yeux bon je m'en
excuse sincèrement désolé j'avais façon
j'ai jamais été très réputé pour pour
avoir des super g que ça il ya des gens
sont réputés parce qu'ils ont des
gameplay of the death de la mort qui tue
il ya des gens ils sont pas réputés et
ils ont pâli appelé de la main de la ds
qui tue et bah moi c'est un peu ça je
veux pas du tout les vieilles plaies de
la main de la destituer d'appeler plutôt
de la main de la ds qui ne suis pas quoi
mais à messieurs je vous jure cette
écriture gauche est devenu mon pire
cauchemar j'en ai rêvé toute la nuit
en plus mon serveur se gamelle comme une
grosse merde je n'y allais oui je vous
jure le reproduire très joueurs c'est un
cauchemar un jour j'aurai la force ma
salle de bain comme brosser les dents il
y aura une écriture en 3d mark est
reproduit hattrick et l'a1 et là je veux
j'appellerais le vendeur que j'aurais
trucider du taux pour acheter ces
sections respectueux et trois mois à fin
janvier bon mon fiston te défoncer la
forêt la banque est brassée de linge
partir d'un délire c'était un délire
oppresseurs pierre la voyez par exemple
juste un enfant j'ai essayé deux fois de
faire cette vidéo à l'aide d'un casque
et je vous jure que je n'y arrivais pas
genre c'est jusqu'à sa psychologie ou
pas psychologie je ne sais pas trop quoi
mais en tout cas je n'arrivais toi mais
si je n'y arrive pas ça ne va pas du
tout
tout d'abord à allah au nom est regardée
alors là j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
ok on va retenter le truc up ou au
maintenant il est le file job en a pas
d'homme beach alors faut surtout pas
hésiter à faire du rewind dont un homme
de jeu y'a pas de soucis ca
c'est fait pour ça ça vous enlève des
points mais à moi vous rattraper votre
figure ça lui donne un max de wazzan
soleiha je vous conseille à mme st-amand
bon je vais avoir de l'argent autant
dire que ea non projet strict
je suis l'acquisition de chimène badi
l'avons l'a pas fait je viens russie
s'est vu partout et les chemins
moi j'adore fait part j'espère que vous
n'allez pas faire mystère des quelques 2
mais crise ou à bitche fidèles au parti
la remplaçante games a procédé en
continu bon allez là c'est allé on gagne
un million n'ont rien que dalle ah bah
oui on gagne un prix si keith arrière
puisque sa ligne d'arrivée connard non
ça ne va plus je te veux même pas encore
voirie vont en tout cas les gens
j'espère que tu en as long as sur game
je vais tout simplement là là je vais
vous avez pu remarquer la chute très
excité j'espère que je vais pouvoir
gratter sachant que moi des scores game
et micromania
ils sont collés les magasins donc je
vais dans l'insomnie non je vais dans
l'autre sinon sur le couteau et à je
plante un jeu en pas le vendeur un jeu
je menace enfin bref il souhaite le
début ce que tu feras et les gens voient
se trouve bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo hot shots monde
bye
[Musique]